today's question comes from cassandra
in north dakota she visits dave
ramsey.com to ask
i know title insurance protects you when
you're buying a house
we have paid off our house and want to
know if we still need this
i'm so confused if we need to purchase
it where do i get it
usaa doesn't offer it so i don't know
what company is trustworthy
where does tidal lock play into this my
husband and i worked so hard to ping off
the house
and don't want anything to jeopardize
that uh you don't need title insurance
you but you either got it or you didn't
when you bought the house
and i wouldn't worry about it at this
stage that ensures that the title that
you were given from the person that sold
it to you is clean
and title lock is something you don't
ever spend money on
and that's the concept that somehow some
company is going to keep someone from
placing a lien on your home
the way this works is simple okay the
property is titled to you
and is recorded with a deed at your
local courthouse
if someone places a lien on your home
they have to
file a lien at the courthouse now for
instance if you didn't pay your taxes
the irs can place a lien on everything
that is in your name
by just simply filing a lien at your
local courthouse
and it would end up as a lien on your
home if you got sued
a judgment lien could be placed against
your home
that's normal but someone borrowing
money
and with identity theft and putting a
lien against your home
it could get filed but it's fairly easy
to get it removed
you need title or you need uh identity
theft
insurance which we recommend and we all
own on ourselves i buy it for all of our
team all of our family
through xander insurance xander's
identity theft program
but there's not a thing that locks your
title
the only other thing you can do if you
want to get
uh super wild about it is you could just
retitle your home to a trust
and then they would have to put a lien
on the trust
not on you so if a lien got placed on
you but even then
that trust owns the house and an
identity thief
could take out a mortgage against a
house that they don't own
and have it recorded at the courthouse
that happens sometimes
but it doesn't happen that often yeah so
the reality is is what you want to do is
get
identity theft insurance with
restoration services
and that's really important some of the
places will just tell you
and alert you if there's been a threat
against your identity
you want something that's going to
restore things back to the way it was
but this title lock this is another
product out there to just try to grab
money this is not something you need uh
be intentional
and if you all are on this journey to
building wealth
as dave mentioned taking a look at a
trust may be an option
reach out to an estate planning attorney
and you can get connected with one of
them
through our smartvestor pros go to
daveramsey.com click on smart vester pro
you'll get connected and start to talk
through this but you you need to relax
be intentional and uh just keep pushing
forward you cannot lock a real estate
title unless you lock the courthouse
door
that's it somebody can file a lien yeah
yeah
and um and these days it would be done
electronically wouldn't be going
physically into the courthouse
and so um you know most most courthouses
now are done
are had all the recording and so forth
is handled online
so um and title searches and so forth
all fall into that same category
so you're going to be fine you'll be
fine i'm glad you're concerned about it
but don't go get
buying you know gimmick insurance or
something get
identity theft insurance from xander and
that's plenty you'll be in good
shape